as we continue to spotlight a new book
each week during the shutdown we turn to
lincoln
on the verge the true story about what
may have been the most difficult moment
in this nation's history and the
extraordinary trip
directly in the middle of it author ted
whitmer details how our nation's 16th
president
survived those pivotal 13 days
november 1860 abraham lincoln is elected
in a four-way contest with just under 40
percent of the votes
but enough to make him the 16th
president storm clouds gathered for
months before lincoln was finally able
to set off for the white house
by train with everything on the line
when he left on this trip he just been
elected president one would think
he's pretty happy to be to be moving
forward and doing this he wasn't
it was the worst presidential transition
in our history for for him and really
for everyone because
it was anything but a joyful event his
election
immediately led to southern promises
that they would succeed and then they
start to do it ted whitmer's new book
lincoln on the verge details the chaos
hijinks deadly threats and narrow
escapes
during 13 days on the rails at the time
he makes this trip seven states have
already seceded
right more more to come more to come but
crucially
the ones they were the most worried
about did not secede
while he was on the train so marilyn
might have gone
and if marilyn goes there's no way he's
he can get to washington
the winding route that began in
springfield illinois
zigged and zagged across seven states
before eventually arriving
in d.c the railroad is behind a lot of
lincoln's career
and he actually loved railroads and he
was a railroad lawyer
and as i argue in the book the train is
a very
important symbol for him of progress
trains could go 60 70 miles an hour
lincoln is moving along pretty fast in
some parts of this
route and the cars he sat
in were quite plush he'd come a long way
from his log
cabin and i described these sort of
elegant sofas and these settees and the
paintings that were hanging in these you
know it's like an early air force one
that he's moving along on
and that was part of the allure people
not only wanted to see abraham lincoln
they wanted to see these very elegant
trains
the presidential train coming through
their small town
so it's not just lincoln that is
exciting to people but the idea of the
presidency itself which had become
pretty weak in the 1850s and after
lincoln's four years the presidency will
always be an important office the
biggest threat of the journey came
from an alleged plot to assassinate the
president-elect
in baltimore lincoln was never eager to
talk about it
but widmer argues in detail it was very
real
the miracle really is that it did not
succeed we all know
how lincoln's life ended in 1865 but i
i came away from the close study of the
assassination plot in 1861 with a
deep sense of gratitude that he made it
at all
whitmer says the plot to kill lincoln
before he could take office
was uncovered by dorothea dix who'd
gained fame for her work with a mentally
handicapped
she in effect became a spy rooting out
dangerous information alan pinkerton
of the famed pinkerton detective agency
and a team of his agents
were recruited to help foil the plot
it's pretty fascinating to hear about
it's a bit like a mission impossible
team they put on southern accents
and they quickly infiltrate the plot and
figure out
the details and that's how word gets to
lincoln that he's got to go through
baltimore in the middle of the night
which he does with alan pinkerton and
one friend
in an ordinary passenger seat at four in
the morning
but a potential assassination while the
gravest of the threats on this trip
was not the only one his son lost his
inaugural address multiple times
welcoming committees were firing cannons
toward the trains right the country's
falling apart
everything is going wrong and he he had
to keep his cool
sometimes his worst enemies were his
friends
sometimes when he came into a town all
of the windows in the train would
shatter because people fired the guns
too close to the train
or in one case a cannon was fired into
the train
so it's it's pretty haphazard he's
trying to
deal with all of that at the same time i
mean he's a normal
guy too he he's lincoln he has these
superhuman talents that are beginning to
be discovered
but he's also just trying to get his
family and his
difficult kids and his difficult wife
from stop to stop on a long train trip
it's a little bit like um a chevy chase
movie
good reference with chevy chase that
came out of nowhere
sounds about right now he kept it
together mentally
and he was always funny when he needs to
be i mean lincoln has a very quick wit
always served him well as a candidate
and as a president
but he's processing all of this deeply
and
thinking hard about a message that can
bring all these very different kinds of
people and one of the
main points of the book is he's seeing
rural people he's seeing city dwellers
he's seeing a lot of immigrants
and what is the special sauce that can
keep
all of these very different people
together and he's saying beautiful
things about what it means to be
american
lincoln's writing and speeches got
better and better
as he was able to effectively harness
and deliver the message he'd been
painstakingly trying to get across from
day one
that saving the republic as it stands
was the only option
for americans then and now i argue in
the end of the book that if the us
doesn't stay together the cause of
democracy
is fatally weakened it wasn't doing very
well
around the world when lincoln was
elected
but by saving american democracy i
believe he
saved the cause of democracy worldwide
and if the united states
hadn't been one powerful country in the
20th century
i think we would have seen a very
different final result in world war
ii and we'd be living in a very
different world today
that is quite something to think about
dana and at last count there were
15 about 15 000 books on lincoln not all
of them
are worth reading lincoln on the verge
is
well once you get a chevy chase
reference and then all i can think is
fletch follow play
and now abraham lincoln too great job
all right